hello guys I'm Ryan right
I'm not feeling at my best right now but
I'm here today because I am blown up
with a request to watch the Captain
America Civil War Superbowl TV spot I
was watching the Superbowl and I knew
people were gonna be requesting
reactions so I didn't watch any of the
commercials I don't want to mislead
people into thinking like I'm trying to
come across like the biggest Marvel
enthusiast I am not that familiar with
the comics but I have seen all the
movies from the MCU several times so
this is me coming from a movie analysis
base my thing is movies
you chose the wrong side
that's cool and that that's some smart
online marketing there see that hashtag
teamcap hashtag team Iron Man but
trailer kind of brought up my mood I'm
gonna watch it again
you chose the wrong side
interesting okay well [ __ ] I don't even
notice him before is that vision
that's totally vision another [ __ ]
Captain America possibly beat Iron Man's
team when he has vision and black
panther they're like equivalent to
having multiple superheroes each one of
those as black panther like I've read a
lot from like websites like Collider
when they're doing reports on Captain
America Civil War but he really is a
superhero you know he's got the speed
the strength the stamina from what I
recall reading he's really good at
picking up like you know this praise
sense that's interesting looking at the
Captain America team you know they got
ant-man there which is cool they know
they reveal that he would be in it I
have a feeling there's gonna be a lot of
people upset at the fact that Zeus
burger man I I honestly hope we don't
see any of spider-man in any of the
promotions I'm really hoping for that
because I want that to just being like
we already know he's gonna be in it let
let the appearance be a nice little
surprise in some way you see and this is
the way you should promote a versus
movie because this is like the first
time were I can't I'm sure there's some
movie out there that really did it well
that you guys will come and let me know
I can't think of anything off the top of
my head but when it comes to Captain
America and Iron Man versing each other
it's a really interesting conflict
you're gonna have because I hope the
movie doesn't pander towards you should
definitely be rooting for Captain
America or you should definitely be
rooting for Iron Man I want to feel the
conflict I want to watch this unfold I
kind of want an experience from going
back and forth like well I should
probably side with Iron Man ah my side
with Kent or I'm at least in the middle
going I get both of your sides but still
you know you shouldn't be fighting but
it looks cool however this isn't called
Captain America vs Iron Man it's called
Captain America Civil War like I
wouldn't be totally surprised if we
found ourselves primarily rooting for
Captain America I mean the odds seem
against him especially with the team
that's formed on his side like when it
comes to superhero powers Iron Man's
team totally wins like cat might have
six
people in total but iron man's five is
equivalent to like a shit-ton mejor and
I love every shot of this TV spot like
it looks cool I haven't been this AM for
a Marvel movie in a long time I'm always
looking forward to them I'm always
somewhat excited for them but I feel
like we get so much of them that my
anticipation for them kind of goes down
but every time I see a trailer for Civil
War especially looking at this new
footage like I really am not sure what
this movie is going to be and I like
that I like that Marvel is promoting a
film room like well it's obviously gonna
play off like a typical Marvel beat
sheet I'm watching this like I feel like
there's gonna be some nice surprises in
this film and I'm really looking forward
to it anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel that uplifted my spirits
thanks for sending in my way out
some love about movies and even trailers
you know let's talk about Mark Ellis
with schmoes and he was saying that he
thinks even TV spots and trailers are a
work of art and they totally are so
kudos to the trailer department here
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today become a reject
and you can follow me on vine and
Instagram those are the main ones I'm
doing and I'm also tweeting more often
so follow me on social media cuz you
tubers like to stay interactive with you
through these other platforms you know
talk about how I don't have a personal
life yet I keep exposing it